so apparently where love is in a
dangerous space finally we are I was not
told until recently though well as we
both discovered for ourselves manning a
ship is not really
oh it's beyond a two-person operation it
really is you know so we played lovers
in a dangerous space-time and it's this
strange indie game where you're inside a
spaceship but you're not controlling the
spaceship directly you're controlling
two people one per player and you move
around the spaceship to access different
control ports which control things like
the weapons on the outside of the ship
or there's a wheel that you can use to
steer the ship as well but you kind of
control everything at once so you're
trying to madly - between these control
ports while shooting enemies that are
attacking you while driving the
spaceship while aiming its deflector
shield and there's just so much going on
and it's super crazy no and of course we
didn't have a higher goal beyond that we
need to rescue these mascots on
to finish you complete each level your
little bunnies in frogs yeah it was
really cute little animals but you know
beyond just like moving the ship around
like that in itself is not as easy as it
sounds it wasn't a matter of just
steering it you needed to point like the
thrusters that like you know like that
kind of pushed the ship it's only aware
the momentum is gone and the whole thing
just required so much cooperation which
I think we didn't quite get in the end
no it's it's the kind of game that you
can't play online or separately you
really have to be sitting next to each
other and the kind of back-and-forth
that you develop as you're trying to
pilot this ship through this really
hostile environment is really cool and
really fun I think yeah it's very
difficult as well but I know that the
ship did as it took damage it was also
able to regenerate health eventually
over time so you know it wasn't so
punished in that if you if both players
completely messed up the cooperating and
deflecting of things attacking and
killing things and steering the ship
away from asteroids and rocks so they
could crash into then you know it was a
doable possible thing exactly yeah and
it looks like every level is also
randomly generated as well so it's the
kind of thing that you can just come
back to if you have a friend over or
something and then you just want to jump
in and be like hey let's play some love
as a dangerous space-time but look I
thought it was really fun and it's
probably my game of the show so far